okay
i decided to start it like right when
you started like drinking the thing
so i'm just trying to work just another
day at work you know
that's not an alcoholic drink though no
no no no he's just got like some
that it what's that [ __ ] you squeeze in
there i got that i got that at [ __ ]
wally world yeah so you just squeeze it
out you squeeze in water flavor it
doesn't have any calories
yeah and it's good man it's looking now
i'm plugging walmart you got me [ __ ]
plugging walmart that's one with apple
cider vinegar apple cider vinegar
terrible apple cider vinegar pineapple
punch or something
i like it she didn't like it i don't
like it just like that apple
that it's just like that vinegar and
another thing too that i noticed that
they did because i
did this accidentally was that they put
the flavor really big like watermelon
and then underneath in little bitty
letters it says with apple cider vinegar
yeah it makes it tart uh if you say so
and i like pickles and smell like paint
yeah he brought that drink in here i'm
like do you smell paint or am i having a
stroke yeah i do smell like paint it
doesn't smell like paint that smells
like paint i was like good i thought it
was just me
all right so we are doing a movie
retrospective
at the moment now one of these this
movie is uh one of the ones that
i don't know if you guys remember but um
uh one of our uh
patrons glenn sent us this big huge box
full of like all
taboo magazines and weird tales and you
know the [ __ ]
blind dead series in the coffin and all
this other kind of stuff and he sent us
some
uh dvds also and i was kind of excited
to do this one because i hadn't seen
this movie in a really long time and i
really really like
the roger corman um edgar allan poe
adaptations
starring vincent price so today we are
doing this
bad boy right here fall of the house of
usher yeah sometimes known as just house
of ushers you don't want to like you
know go too much into it these are old
school flicks
but they got class this [ __ ] came out
in 1960.
good color palette good-looking cast
they always got
like cute women in them and uh [ __ ]
vincent price being himself and [ __ ]
dressing up like me
i got that outfit with the red [ __ ]
and the black and i got that
and i even had my hair [ __ ] dyed or
had my hair [ __ ] uh bleached out
[ __ ] white when i did that
i got pictures to [ __ ] prove it and i
didn't even know he was dressing like
that
this was actually this is an interesting
movie
yeah um especially in regards to
uh horror in the united states now this
was actually the first
of the uh american international
pictures or aip
uh the first of the very famous edgar
allen poe adaptations
now prior to this um aip and
roger corman in particular had been
known obviously for doing a lot of
really cheap
black and white you know sci-fi movies
big bug moments
yeah lots of walking like lots of water
lots of walking lots of driving lots of
cars going around yeah
lots of padding is what yeah we love
pads the film yeah
lots of talking lots of sitting in the
office talking over the phone to another
[ __ ]
and what did the scientists say oh and
they said the asteroid was going what
yes and you know we all know that
asteroids fly through space
and when they come down they become
meteorites so they hit they hit on the
ground they become a meteorite
i didn't know that it's good to know
that call the army general
they're doing that [ __ ] [ __ ] concept
and then he calls the army general
next scene yeah in the different regions
yeah general williams did you know about
asteroids of course i know about that
i'm going to tell you all about that i'm
going to tell you all about asteroids
the [ __ ] whole movie you're talking
on the phone what is it like
teenage caveman which i think which i if
i'm not mistaken was also a roger corbin
movie that came in the 50s
um i think like fully three quarters of
that movie is
people walking around walking around
yeah walking around or it's like i said
walking around or cars pulling in and
out
lots of that [ __ ] yeah but the thing is
is that these movies are actually like
the high class
[ __ ] corbin flicks they're they're
like a big product this is what kind of
kills me they look good
in there and let me hold let me finish
i'm gonna say this about these movies
they're kind of an acquired they're an
acquired taste if you're kind of like a
modern person
these are very much like plays yeah like
stage x
they're very [ __ ] theatrical and [ __ ]
but that's like a hammer film
yeah but that that's that's the that's
the appeal of this kind of movie it's
gothic horror
yeah yeah it's what it is so yeah so
roger corman and aip
have been known for doing those types of
movies now
by the time the late 50s and early 60s
started rolling around
um those movies weren't doing as well
um you know so aip was kind of facing
not i don't know if they were like
teetering on the edge of bankruptcy but
they were like losing money and they
were kind of like freaking out about it
so then they noticed that hammer films
from the uk
were starting to you know leech into the
public consciousness and seem to be very
successful
so uh hold on before you get into that
hammer films were successful because
they had
[ __ ] cute women and lots of cleavage
yeah cleavage and blood
yeah they'd put them in those [ __ ]
bustiers and [ __ ] you know what i
mean all the [ __ ] old-fashioned
there had to be a lot of cleavage and
they had to be [ __ ] smoking hot
and they got pictures to prove just go
ahead and watch one
well we even did uh i think we haven't
done that many hammer movies but we did
do twins of evil
yeah and uh i i think i joked on that
review it's like that should be called
down blouse the movie
yeah it's just looking down two hot
twins that were in it
yeah and it's like and it was like so
funny because it was like so blatant she
was like
hey look at this everybody yeah you're
like leading
and they're they're [ __ ] you know
it's 1960s and 70s so you're talking
playboy bunny material they're good
looking
european actresses yeah you know well
that was like i said that was a winning
combination yeah they were famous over
there for that [ __ ] they were bringing
it over here it was working
it was weird so that was kind of you
know getting into the thing like i said
there was still
you know teen bikini like sci-fi type of
movies like into the 60s
but it does seem like you know the 50s
that was kind of the heyday of it the
black and white ones and stuff
so roger corman who had made [ __ ] like
attack of the crab monsters and all that
kind of stuff
he comes to aip and he says how about we
do
a po adaptation now they said
now can you do two black and white films
for i believe a hundred thousand dollars
each
and he said tell you what if we do the
poe adaptation
can we do it for 200 000 but do it in
technicolor
and they were like well the hammer
movies have been pretty successful and
[ __ ] like that so okay
go for it now apparently the first one
that roger corman wanted to do
was mask of the red death but for
whatever reason that wasn't the first
one that got made the first one that got
made was fall of the house of usher
probably because house of usher
is the most i guess narrative of poe's
stories in the sense that there is
actually like a conflict there's
actually a story behind it
because a lot of pose stories are very
atmosphere
yeah yeah not much happens in them right
and once something happens
it's not like plot driven yeah yeah it's
mostly atmospheric yeah
you know and that's that's that's what
lovecraft is trying to do later
right yeah same kind of thing same kind
of thing so
um so i think they chose that one for
the first now i will say i've seen a lot
of adaptations
of the fall of the house of usher i
believe and i don't know if this is
still true
but i believe that the fall of the house
of usher is the second most adapted
pose story like after well it's the
first most apt to post story because the
raven is the first one and that's a poem
um but yeah so i think this is even
though this deviates from
the original story it's still i think
the most
similar adaptation of the story that
i've seen
you know what i'm saying even though
they changed some [ __ ] like to make it
like an 80-minute movie or however long
it is
so what they do with this there's only
four characters
in this movie because like i said the
the story is just very much it's one
location it's very few characters
um and [ __ ] so what they did was they
had vincent price playing
roderick usher now he said that because
in the story
roderick usher is supposed to be like
really really sickly and like really
cadaverous and like really pale and thin
and everything like that
so he had to go like on a crash diet i
guess vincent price is a it was a big
dude i mean he was a big
how tall was this [ __ ] football or
something like that
so he was this big lumbering it wasn't
like you know hefty or anything but he
was
medium build real tall though yeah yeah
so he actually had to like starve a lot
and like kind of pale
up for the [ __ ] role for some reason
they put a blonde wig on him in this i'm
going to look good
it did um because i don't i don't
remember it seems like every other
adaptation of this that i've seen
um roderick usher is dark-haired because
that's what you would think of because
it's like super gothy and everything
was just think of him like he had that
burgundy frock coat
or the color looked better again yeah
and the black because that's what i
found
because you know i have that outfit
pretty much just like mine's actually
better
it's better but with the black [ __ ]
black [ __ ] collar
black shirt with a black collar and a
[ __ ] tie and a [ __ ] burgundy
[ __ ] frock
coat and it looks really good blonde
hair especially if you got colored eyes
if you're [ __ ] green or blue eyes it
[ __ ] boom
she would see me in that outfit in the
club she's that's how i got it
well because you're a snappy dresser a
lot of dudes aren't snappy dressers
that's back in the day though it's that
shit's kind of played out now you know
but
yeah he had like all these big long
frock coats and like all this i was like
man that dude looks pretty cool look at
this yeah you can only
i burned those out nobody else will even
wear them anymore because i had if i
made a patent on that [ __ ] in this local
area [ __ ] if you dress like that they
think you're copying me yeah
and they said because i had a bust
because i had a bunch of that [ __ ]
yeah one if it was black you could get
away with it yeah but if it was colors
and [ __ ]
certain colors yeah i got known for that
because you got white ones and red ones
white ones
yeah yeah it didn't [ __ ] didn't
[ __ ] babysass was trying to come at
me with [ __ ] light blue ones and
[ __ ] green ones remember didn't you
have like a
like a neon orange one yeah an orange
was trying to because
it was it was too tacky baby
i'm not going
i just think it's funny that you called
babies it was like it was like some
single white female [ __ ]
yeah i couldn't get rid of that dude it
was like really weird
but you love me you know you love me man
get the [ __ ] out of here dude what are
you talking about it was so weird
yeah that was a weird time yeah yeah
yeah but yeah so um
so they have like um the really cool
like the house of usher which i assume
is like a um
is like a what do you call it a matte
painting it looks like
um so they have like the main character
of his name is philip winthrop in the
movie
now in this story uh the narrator is not
named he's just a dude that used to be
like a friend of rodericks and he gets a
letter from roderick saying hey bro i'm
really sick you know can you come and
see me maybe you'll cheer me up and
you know everything's going to [ __ ] or
whatever now i think this
it's interesting because in this uh
movie which was uh the script was
written by richard matheson
by the way so there you go um they
actually made it where philip winthrop
the guy was coming there
because he was engaged to marry
madeleine usher the sister of roderick
usher
now they're not twins in the movie even
though they are in the book which is
kind of
you know in the story that was kind of
like a big theme was like the doubling
you know what i mean because they're
like twins and like they had opposite
maladies and [ __ ] like that
so there was a lot of that so they kind
of like got rid of that but i can see
why they
did because they wanted like a narrative
thrust they wanted more of a conflict
because what ends up happening is that
philip
comes to the house essentially to take
madeleine away from the house because he
thinks that
it's causing her to be ill like it's
causing her illness
and uh it's also kind of implied
i guess i don't know if i'm just reading
this into it i'm not the only person
that's read this into it if i am but
it's also implied that the relationship
between the brother and sister might be
a touch
incestuous a lot of literature [ __ ]
implied that from the [ __ ] eighteen
hundreds and seventies
you noticed that i think i think in the
movie they kind of imply
yeah and i think i think incest [ __ ]
was kind of a thing
yeah i mean mary shelley was [ __ ]
wrote some [ __ ] strange [ __ ] about
her dad
yeah you know what i'm inflicting that
she kind of had some kind of weird thing
for her dad but she didn't ever see him
it's kind of just
it's hard to tell because it seemed like
yeah the way that they wrote back then
and like
hard to tell the way like even the way
two men that were friends would like
write to each other like nowadays people
would be like wow
no homo bro or whatever it was but it
seems like romantic
yeah but i think it wasn't really maybe
well it's hard it wasn't always like
that
mary shell mary shelley and her [ __ ]
husband
they wrote some weird [ __ ] and they had
[ __ ] going on with other couples and
stuff but just
she would talk about her dad as
that man you know that man not seeing
that man and
that man that man mystifies me and that
man and he's been gone
and it was kind of weird that is kind of
a weird way yeah she called him that man
because she never she wasn't raised
around him
well that i guess that's kind of
different because that does end up
happening sometimes
yeah um in like incest situations
where you don't have the incest ickiness
raised like with that sibling or with
that parent and sometimes particularly
this happens a lot between siblings i'm
not sure what the percentage is
but sometimes siblings that were raised
apart
like when they get back together they're
just like all about it yeah it's weird
and there's like been reports weird [ __ ]
goes down between twins that's been
going on for a long time
well yeah i think it's mostly tense
towards twin females but
uh there's a lot of rumors between some
of the twin mark remember the barbie
twins
those models there was like a bunch of
rumors about what was going on with
those two
nothing ever confirmed it's just it's
just weird [ __ ] man that's not
[ __ ] how you can explain that [ __ ] you
can't really explain it
that's what i mean okay well here's
something
ramses you know [ __ ] king ramsay's
egyptian queen
egyptian king back in the [ __ ] what
was that middle kingdom i think it was
i believe so yeah i don't know middle
dynasty yeah it was middle middle
middle king and also [ __ ] timogen
also known as genghis khan they had huge
[ __ ] harems
and sometimes the
the the children of the harems there are
[ __ ] thousands of [ __ ] wives in
some cases or hundreds of wives the
children of the harem centers would
marry back
into half brothers yeah and weird [ __ ]
like the some of some of
some of uh evidently king ramsay's
wives were also his daughters from the
harems
but yeah weird on a genetic level but
you could understand that
the in a certain way that the harem was
on a heavy rotation
or you know i mean they were on a
rotation so that he might he had
hundreds of them so he only saw him with
me once a month
so he didn't even know the mom he had
like a schedule yeah somebody had to
keep track of that you might
see one he might excuse me if i say once
a month he said he might see one once
once a year i was gonna say yes or once
every couple years once a month he must
be going yeah
so so not only did he not know the
daughter he
really know the mother yeah so you know
whatever and they were just random
people just a bunch of women yeah just a
bunch of women
you know and they were doing it for kind
of practical reasons
religion permitted it because their gods
were doing that
but it made more sense that all your all
of your government
employees and your all your government
positions were filled by people that
were
directly related to you so there was no
treason
yeah you know what i mean and no
intrigue so it got rid of palace
intrigue
that's what's the main thing yeah
because you were literally betraying
your own father and your own family
so perfect loyalty yeah they didn't know
anything about [ __ ] inbreeding
they i think they figured out later but
well they didn't know anything about
genetics or anything like that
i mean that you'd think that they would
have noticed it like after a while it's
like hey if we keep but i don't know i
don't know if it happened often enough
for them to like i think
yeah well i think in the case i think in
the case of like the ancient egyptians
and timogen and [ __ ]
they were so the the the herd of the was
so huge
they couldn't breed back in on
themselves too many times
yeah yeah i mean so that's true it
wouldn't it wouldn't happen too many
times
but yeah regardless that was all the
incest [ __ ] [ __ ]
so they didn't so they didn't uh make
them twins obviously in
the adaptation and actually um
you know vincent price playing the role
was actually much older obviously
because they were supposed to be the
same age
so it almost comes across as like not
even a brother and sister it almost
comes across like father and daughter so
it's like a little bit like weirder
there
and like i said it also seems a little
bit incestuous in the sense that this
guy
who apparently madeline had like kind of
a regular life which i don't think they
really refer to in the story
but um she had a regular life in boston
she was doing whatever she was doing
and this guy phillip met her there and
then
for whatever reason she got sick or
something and then she came back to like
the ancestral home
and um vincent price's character
roderick now thinks that
she can't leave yeah most mostly because
what
not now that you're not now that you're
talking about it's more what i'm
thinking about yeah
they're they're um they're implying
incest
and i think they're implying incest
through generations of the family it's
not yeah it's not super overt
yeah but it you know what though knowing
kind of how the victorians were
during the area with era when this was
written that would have added to the
element of creep
yeah because that was in a lot of gothic
language they would have thought that
[ __ ] was pretty
[ __ ] creepy so that's probably what
they're talking about it's a horror
story
yeah so you know what i mean i don't
think it was it wasn't normal
for for the 1800s but i think it creeped
them out because they knew that it
happened
yeah so that was something i mean
between that and between being
uh buried alive which is another kind of
like poe thing that he put in a bunch of
his stories which is in this as well
obviously
a weird [ __ ] plays on the drug
addiction theme they talked about that a
lot in
in gothic horror being addicted to
something
jekyll and hyde type [ __ ] and i feel
like this one
this story in particular and this kind
of comes across in the movie as well
is that you know the house itself uh
the house of usher like i said the the
title of it is like a dual meeting it
not only refers to
the actual house but it also refers to
the usher
family bloodline um and so basically
they kind of play up in the
movie how degenerate uh
this line is yeah and how i love
i have to say that i love the [ __ ]
paintings
like the family paintings are super cool
like something out of the
even better than the the haunted house
out of disneyland yeah they're like
they're
super creepy like of all the because
they're like all the mass murderers and
the impressionistic and [ __ ] like yeah
yeah i looked up because i looked up i
was like i wonder who did those
paintings because those are so [ __ ]
cool it reminded me like some night
gallery [ __ ]
his name is actually bert sean berg is
the name of the artist that did those
paintings and i'll put some pictures i
found some pictures of somebody had a
blog yeah
it's an incest type thing that an evil
bloodline
yeah that's kind of what they're writing
that's what they're playing on the
incest theme
i think yeah and it's also i've seen
like
maybe not so much the movie but the
story they kind of talk about
how poe might have been referring to
um the degeneracy and the dying out of
the aristocracy
like as a whole and you know that that
was a factor in the aristocracy
right because as these two this brother
and sister
are the last of the line and supposedly
the line is cursed
and roderick usher whether this is
actually the case or not has come to
believe
that the degeneracy in the family line
in their bloodline has
manifested itself in physical form
in the sense of the house so the house
is crumbling the
land around the house is dead like
nothing will grow on it
so it's you know it's like sinking into
this [ __ ]
pit you know what i mean like it's
sinking into a swamp essentially the
house is like cracking in half
so it's kind of like the symbolism of
the house
falling apart as you know as the family
falls apart and also
as their um as their sanity crumbles
the house and the family and the mind of
the family all one and the same are all
one and the same
they're talking about incest problems
that's what they're talking about well
yeah and i do feel like
you know and i think like i said it's
not real overt in the movie it's not
real overt in the story even
but i do think that that's something
that was going on like the way they talk
about like the family line being cursed
and everything
and like i said when he goes around with
all the um the paintings
and he's basically like this is you know
a murderous and a poisoner
this is like a thieves and you know
pirates and like all this other kind of
[ __ ] so all these people were like
terrible people
so he's basically roderick is basically
saying
this line should die out because we're
digi and that's why he doesn't want
madeleine to leave
because he doesn't i guess he doesn't
want her getting out well he doesn't
want her
um you know and like i said this is a
little bit different than the story but
kind of on
along the same lines he doesn't want her
to leave and marry and have children and
carry this line on
to subject the rest of the world to this
horrible
to these horrible people if you guys
want to see a real
the real uh house of usher and family of
the house of usher
just go on youtube and [ __ ] search
for inbred family
and you'll find like one of the top ones
and the video is only i think about a
year old and there's a couple of them
there's a family up in appalachia that's
[ __ ] badly in bread
and uh they visit them quite often and
talk to them and they just sit out on a
porch they got little bitty heads there
one of them just barks like a dog he
can't talk he just boom boom boom
barks like a dog and hangs out with the
dogs it's [ __ ] up
and uh don't they isn't there like one
family in particular i can't remember
and i'm just like this is
a drool and [ __ ] they just sit there and
drool but there's one family in
particular that's been so and it may be
them but
that they've been in bread so long that
they're like the source of like all
these scientific studies
yeah they kind of take care of them you
know because they want to know like more
about like what kind of genetics i think
it might be the same one i think there's
only like five of them yeah there's not
that many that have been that they all
live in this house and the doors and
windows are always wide open and it just
it's [ __ ] eerie man and they just
kind of live out on a damn porch and
across the street
of the road if they got a damn trailer
it's fog [ __ ] caved in and then they
as they die they just bury them right
there you know the one guy he's barking
and he's calling him over and pointing
down to the ground and that's where
what's his name where he died as they
die they just bury him right there
well yeah but evidently the state knows
about them they they kind of take care
of like i said they might be
like the source of yeah there was like
brother and sister married and over over
well not really marion just
talking over and over and over again
they're considered themselves married
it's [ __ ] bizarre man they sit there
and get on teeth and [ __ ] they just
drool
it's uh creep you the [ __ ] out
and brad family yeah but yeah so
so basically what they did like i said
with the story is which i think was a
good decision
uh on richard matheson's part to make
the
narrator in the in the original story
who was like i said a childhood friend
of roderick's and the story he was just
coming to see him because he was sick or
whatever
i like that they made it you know
madeleine's
like boyfriend essentially so that there
was more conflict because
look i gotta take you away from here
your brother's insane he wants to kill
you and uh you know he thinks that the
house is trying to kill me and also
because
[ __ ] happens to phillip when he first
gets to like the chandelier falls and
like
[ __ ] falls off and like um you know and
so vincent price's character is like you
know you those weren't accidents like
the house is legit trying to kill you
because the house is like a living
entity
essentially um so obviously philip
thinks that uh
roderick is crazy and that madeleine
needs to get away from there because he
thinks that that's what's causing her
illness is this this insane brother like
keeping her trapped in this house and
the movie is less ambiguous because i
feel like the story
is more you don't really know you don't
know the narrator's name
you don't know if he's perceiving things
the way they really are you don't know
if the ushers are perceiving things the
way they really are
because there's the whole thing about
roderick having
that weird unnamed malady where
everything is heightened like his
hearing is really acute
his sense of taste is so acute that all
he can eat is mush it's like he has to
wear super soft clothes all the time
because he's like super super sensitive
to stimuli
whereas madeleine has the opposite thing
she has catalepsy
which means that she falls into these
kind of like trances where she
seems to be dead um which they don't
really reveal in the movie until the end
um because basically what roderick does
is he i guess he upsets her to such an
extent that she goes into one of these
catalysts
catalytic states and then he just chucks
her in the coffin in the ball
and he sees her hand moving and he's
just like oh well
slam and then he tails her in there and
then she like busts out and she's um
a little upset about it as you would be
uh which like i said that's
the kind of the same thing that happened
in the story but you know they
they did enough of the story that you
can
tell that that's what it is but they had
to change a couple things like to
pad out the running time even so like i
said this is a very
stage play like movie um it's like a
hammer film it's very
talky um a lot of the first
hour of the movie is basically um
conflict between roderick and philip
about
madeleine leaving and just them arguing
with each other and just like other kind
of creepy [ __ ] like her taking
um like madeleine taking philip down to
the family vault and
being like here's my coffin it's waiting
for me because she's all death obsessed
and
him trying to argue with her get her to
leave like you know you can't stay here
this is not good for you
and all this other kind of stuff and
then like it really doesn't like
ramp up until the end like after
you know towards the end like when
madeline actually dies
or you know they think that she dies or
roderick knows she's not dead he just
puts her in there because he's just like
look we all gotta die just hurry up just
get in there you know what i mean
and it's like he puts her in there and
then the whole thing happens just like
in the story where he starts hearing
funny noises in the house
and like knows that she's busted out of
her coffin and
is like coming back to get him and like
they all die and everything goes up in
big conflagration
i have to say like i said even though
this movie probably only cost
a hundred thousand dollars 200 000 max
to make
it looks [ __ ] great i mean it's
really really
nobody could like work a set
like roger corman he could make these
really great like
gothic looking mansions and [ __ ] like
that for like nothing and it still
looked really cool yeah um and he's
in this case they're trying to replicate
what you saw in hammer and they do
they do a pretty good job it is i mean i
had to give the edge to a hammer flick
yeah but this is a good this is a good
uh response to hammer
i mean i really like like i'm assuming
like i said the house from the outside
like the exterior shots and the woods
and everything i assumed that that was a
matte painting but that was a really
good matte painting
um at the end when the house like
basically starts crumbling and then like
burns up in a big conflagration
um that looks really good i read
somewhere that
that the last part of this where the
house like burns up and everything
that uh roger corman liked how that
turned out so much that he used it again
and like some of the other
movies he's like that looks fantastic
let's like save money and like you
yeah but yeah that would do well yeah
and like
that's what i said that's why no roger
corman movie has ever lost money
um or that was kind of like the story i
don't know if some of his later ones did
if you got it there man take a bunch of
footage and just save it so you need it
later well that's what he said
another thing that roger corman would do
i don't know if he did it on this
particular one but he would
have one set and he would film two
movies like simultaneously
this movie took yeah just different
setting different dressing on the set
yeah because it doesn't take for movies
you know who else did that the hong kong
theater
yeah hong kong theater did they get
exact same thing they'd be shooting six
movies at once all using the same
[ __ ] cast they just [ __ ]
change their [ __ ] costumes
and if you had a theater crew that were
used to like changing
sets out like really quickly like you
could do it like
just in a couple of minutes you could
have like the whole set looks completely
different
some of those hong kong [ __ ] studios
could uh basically make eight movies for
the price of one
yeah so well similar yeah so that's
similar to what roger gorman was doing
and i mean this movie looked really
great um and
it was very successful i mean it came
out and it made
like a million dollars like just in the
first like couple days it was out
and um amazingly even though like i said
it's a very
um it's kind of a slow stagey
you know gothic horror that's you know
very very close to the original story
with like some
some other elements added to it but it
was actually a really big success
and the success of that actually led to
the sort of golden age of aip's
poe adaptations now the best known ones
nowadays are the eight
that roger corman made um but there were
a couple more that they did that other
people directed but they're not as well
remembered
because roger corman as cheap jack as he
was
actually did have kind of an artistic
eye and he did
know what he was doing um plus it helped
that
seven of those eight roger corbin movies
had vincent price
in the main role and who doesn't love
vincent price man
i mean he is just like he's not super
over the top in this one not as over the
top as say the pit and the pendulum
which came out the year after this one
that was like the next one
um you know where he was just like got
to play like a cackling villain which i
kind of love
but um but he's kind of a little bit
over the top in this one
a little bit well evidently price
in the context of the time i guess you
could say he was
he was the audiences were comfortable
with him they knew who it was
yeah and they liked him and evidently he
was popular with kids
and that's who really we're going to the
movies a lot yeah that's why i went to
see this
right weirdly look there's no there's
nothing explicit in it
yeah there's no boobs it's not real
bloody there's some blood but not a ton
so the kid and the kid i remember i
would [ __ ] watch him on you know like
monster mash
matinee and [ __ ] and just his voice
alone would creep me the [ __ ] out when
you're six
seven eight nine ten that's true like
something
something bad is gonna happen well you
always knew something bad
was in the shop so yeah because you know
and just him talking
the way he's talking the way he looked
well you know just he was just a creepy
dude
yeah yeah yeah and then in the back
behind him you know there'd be lightning
through the window shades you're like oh
[ __ ] that's just like the [ __ ]
disneyland haunted house
and then later on they might show you a
skeleton you're like oh [ __ ] man the
damn skeletons
but nothing would really happen but you
didn't notice that nothing really
happened when you were a kid you're like
glad that's over with i made it i made
it
that made it through that whole [ __ ]
thing made it like survived it
that's all yeah it's kind of like cool
because yeah even though you could say
in a movie like this well even you could
say it about edgar allan poe's stories
you could say it about h.p lovecraft
stories it's like nothing really happens
in them in the sense that you know
that's not like this big
like plot driven kind of thing it's
mostly it's mostly just
atmosphere and then it just kind of
builds up to this like climax at the end
then it ends you know what i mean
yeah they were safe to watch a few years
later my dad you know i'm a little kid
my dad takes me to see alien one in the
theater and there's no escaping that
like oh
[ __ ] i think busting out that dude
that was about [ __ ] love that movie
and
do not believe what they [ __ ] say on
the [ __ ] news or on television
kids love to be scared i love that it's
just scaring the [ __ ] out of me
i'm just scared for [ __ ] days i
[ __ ] loved it i did too
if i wasn't scared i just yeah it wasn't
worth the money well it wasn't good
and then a few years later then it takes
me to go see the thing
that [ __ ] blew my [ __ ] mind man i
loved it
but like i said there's something to be
said for these because i love hammer
films i love these edgar allan poe
adaptations i think um
follow the house of usher is not my
favorite mask of the red death is
probably my favorite but that's just
because
mask of the red death is probably my
favorite pose story
either that or the telltale heart i just
love those so much um
and the whole like aesthetic of mask of
the red death with all the different
colored rooms and that black clock and
all the [ __ ]
masks and [ __ ] i love that kind of like
aesthetic so i'm kind of into that
um but i feel like roger corman wanted
to make mask of the red death
from the beginning but for whatever
reason he didn't get to
he made it later though he made it later
four years later like i think pitt and
the pendulum was the one that came out
after this and then
maybe the raven based on my mask
i haven't seen any of these in a long
time based on my memory pitting the
pendulum was the [ __ ] scariest one
but that's just
i remembered that i liked that one i
remember that one that one kind of stuck
out some of the
some of the scenes from that but i like
i said we gotta see him again i mean
they're all good
um all of all of that you know that run
of edgar
imagery is that [ __ ] pendulum coming
out of that blade disturbed me as a kid
well that's pretty freaky to think of
because think about what you what
it would feel like to be in that
situation i think that's why like
guillotines and stuff like that or
guillotines before you froze about it
um you know that kind of imagery has
always freaked me out because all i can
think of is what would it be like
to just be in that thing and know that
it was gonna happen like in a couple of
seconds that must be
the worst feeling it'd be like getting
hit in the back of the back of the neck
with a [ __ ] baseball bat you wouldn't
feel the blade you just feel an impact
bow and your blood pressure would
[ __ ]
decline real [ __ ] rapidly but i
probably knock you out
i can't think of a worse it's well the
the thing of it actually happening
but i can't think of a worse feeling
than knowing it was going to happen what
would be worse is [ __ ]
that hearing that thing falling coming
down that's what i'm saying
i'd be like riding a roller coaster
except you're not on the roller coaster
the roller coaster is coming to you
except you're not getting off the roller
coaster
yeah yeah so it's like all that kind of
stuff and you can see this i mean edgar
allen poe he's like the og goth right
because
all of his [ __ ] he's like he just loved
all the [ __ ] graves and being buried
alive and
beautiful women dying of unknown
diseases
and like wasting away and like walking
through the house like in like white
nightgowns like all creepy and [ __ ]
it was a good movie it did not deliver
on the cleavage [ __ ] angle that's
only madeleine was only woman in it and
she didn't have
a lot of clever that's that wouldn't
have happened if the british were
involved if this was a hammer flick
she'd be in a bustier yeah drowning in
her own titties
the way gothic horror should be that
just shit's just like up here you know
like she's standing upside down you can
rest your chin on yeah it's like she's
standing on her hands
[ __ ] you know dude that's the way it
should be yeah there's a beautiful
there's a beautiful woman in this though
but yeah
she's she just wears like i do like that
red velvet number she wears like
but it's not like super cleavage
but yeah um oh i have to say too i
wanted to mention that
there is a really cool silent film
adaptation of fall of the house of usher
i think two adaptations
like silent ones came out in 1928 um the
one i'm talking about is like the really
weird
surreal one because there's one that was
kind of straightforward but there was a
really weird like creepy art film like
surreal one and it's [ __ ] great and i
think i think it's on youtube or it used
to be because that's where i saw it
but it's like super cool because i think
it's probably almost in the public
domain at this point
but yeah it's like if you really like
poe adaptations if you really love
vincent price if you haven't seen this
this is the first of the uh you know
roger corman edgar allen poe adaptations
and was so successful that they made
like a ton more
and um probably the best movies well not
even probably easily the
best movies roger corman ever made he's
you know who knew he had it in him
after all after attack of the crab
monsters and teenage cavemen and all
that
some of the stuff he made was pretty
good though yeah yeah he was he wasn't a
hack
no way uh it just depended on what the
project was
like um galaxy of terror that brought
[ __ ] no what's his name into that
that was actually a pretty good flag
yeah yeah they had said hague in it and
everything that yeah it was it was a
fake it was an alien one ripoff
yeah but it was it brought who's to do
the determination again what's his name
james cameron yeah he brought cameron
and because he did most of special
effects for it
and um they did all that [ __ ] came in
under budget and
i got to get galaxy of terror i don't
have it but that is that is actually a
very good one you get to see a girl
[ __ ] raped by a damn huge maggot
it's huge pretty messed up the thing's
about 40 50 feet long
and also don't you get dripping don't
you get to see joni from happy days get
like blown up
yeah yeah she gets blown up and the sets
were good
in case you ever wanted to see that and
that and you know corman knew that
for that one they were gonna have to
spend some money and they took a [ __ ]
risk with uh cameron and that movie did
well
did very well did very well on cable too
yeah because they played that [ __ ] on
[ __ ] hbo and cinemax constantly
yeah and because that scene with that
[ __ ] big old caterpillar
ripping that girl's space suit off and
she had them figured that was like yeah
she was [ __ ] hot too she's all in the
slime
[ __ ] rubbing on her and [ __ ]
like that you know because it's making
your it's affects the [ __ ] that play
because of that scene
because of that scene it was almost
x-rated and they put that [ __ ] on
late at night on [ __ ] cinemax and
when you were a 14 year old [ __ ] boy
you and all your other boys have stamped
to watch that [ __ ] holy mary it's coming
we watch that [ __ ] [ __ ] every time we
got over
you know guys and terrorists coming off
oh man that [ __ ] worms coming the big
caterpillar
yeah that was funny sean poe
sean poe oh actually i just i just got
this the other day
check this out this is super cool show
the show show the picture first
show the picture first yeah one picture
i'll picture one in front of a box okay
okay okay never mind see that's a
picture yeah
yeah he looks real happy in that yeah po
poke and close the show
popo popo the popo yeah look check out
this cool [ __ ] mug i got it from uh
unemployed philosophers guild or
whatever they're called
it's all quotes from poe stories isn't
that awesome
yeah i [ __ ] love i love it so much
that it's like i don't want to use it
because i'm afraid it's gonna break or
it's gonna like
get all [ __ ] up in the dishwasher or
something i have to wash this [ __ ] by
hand
but yeah so seriously uh we might
eventually get around to doing uh some
of the other poe adaptations that roger
corman did especially mask of the red
death because i think that's my favorite
one but also put in the pendulum is very
good too
this one like i said very significant
because it was the first one
uh you know and kind of like saved uh
aip
pictures from bankruptcy uh you know and
so like
like i said i think it's cool because
nowadays you would think like kids
wouldn't go see this movie but they
totally did
because i guess it was like creepy and
scary and everything like that so yeah
if you're into like kind of classic
horror want some hammer but done
american and also if you like poe if you
like vincent price
then check it out it's really awesome
see you later